pop
[Musique]
key
l'audience est ouverte veuillez vous
asseoir
accusés quels sont vos noms et prénoms
nous on chez se loge émilienne vous
n'êtes ni à quelle date et à quel
endroit le 19 juillet 1949 à doué
qu'elle est maintenant votre père
charles nom et prénom votre maire
charles dussault
asseyez-vous il va être procédé à
l'appel des jurés vous voudrez bien
répondre présent et au fur et à mesure
je met à vous non dans l'urne
je suis rémy d'un parent trésor madame
luce bons voisins présente monsieur
visio présence monsieur narcisse michel
présent est ce que michel goubert raison
madame geneviève gurrey présent je suis
alex marodon parce que michel huss
présent monsieur jacques s'il ya
monsieur fernand landrieu monsieur
alexandre duchêne damas guy harvey
raison de ce genre mines mesnil à la
mesure jacques de l'esstin madame josée
lennar madame nathalie collin exemple
monsieur roger gagné réseau madame
jocelyne olivier henin monsieur andré
poupon présent je refais de la matière
monsieur bonus grandclaude 4 puisque
j'en avance a accusé il va être
considéré à l'appel du jury chargé de
vous juger
je rappelle à monsieur l'avocat général
et à la défense leur droit de récusation
mesdames et messieurs vous voudrez bien
prendre place aux côtés de la cour dans
l'ordre fixé par le sort et au fur et à
mesure du tirage le dire on sort
monsieur alexandre duchêne monsieur
alexandre duchêne vous êtes premier juré
comme thème ou s'il n'y avait plus la
feuille des questions liées à prendre
place aux côtés de la dame tout cas ce
monsieur rémy d'arbas récuser métiers
d'art place vous est récusé par la
défense japd y gagnent monsieur jean
l'avant ça madame nathalie klein alors
josé lennar sociaux narcisse kiel shell
patron monsieur roger de la voix pierre
madame maggie hardy accusé al ahmar dit
vous êtes accusé par la défense
neuvième et dernier jurés sauf
récusation
monsieur michel gobert que le greffier
veuillez faire l'appel du jury le jury
composé de monsieur du chef madame me
suit il ya monsieur l'avant ça madame
collin madame lennard monsieur michel
monsieur de la voix pierre et monsieur
joubert
mesdames et messieurs les jurés veuillez
vous lever la foule va recevoir notre
serment vous voudrez bien la main a
relevé dire je le jure voici le texte du
serment que vous avez à prêter aux jurés
et promettez devant dieu et devant les
hommes d'examiner avec l'attention la
plus scrupuleuse des charges qui seront
portées contre lui aux anges et solange
de ne trahir ni les intérêts de l'accusé
ni ceux de la société qui l'accusent de
ne communiquer avec personne jusqu'à
prévoir déclarations de n'écouter li na
n où la méchanceté ni la crainte ou
l'affection que vous décidez d'après les
charges et les moyens de défense
suivant votre conscience et votre intime
conviction avec l'impartialité et la
firme outil qui conviennent à un homme
probe et libre et de conserver les
secret des délibérations même après la
cessation de vos fonctions
monsieur duchesne vue
madame quatre chefs jusque tilly a jugé
monsieur l'avant ça je jure à l'âme
collège madame lennard réussir monsieur
michel je le jure monsieur de la
papetière te jure monsieur gobeil
je le jure voyez vous asseoir la cour
prend acte de votre serment
c'est déclare le jury définitivement
constitué mesdames et messieurs les
autres jurés vous êtes libre vous pouvez
vous retirer
monsieur lui s'il va les faire l'appel
des témoins qui répondront présents à
l'appel de leur nom témoins cités à la
requête du ministère public
monsieur le grand monsieur philippe
castet présent madame vos de barrier
hasard monsieur papiers présents
mademoiselle papiers fraser la
demoiselle belfond présente monsieur
frugère présent
madame frugère raisin témoins cités à la
requête de la défense monsieur le
docteur farce
monsieur lusanger présent que les
témoins se retire de la salle qui leur
est réservé ils ne pourront servir que
pour déposer accusé soyez attentive à ce
que vous allez entendre monsieur le
greffier a donné lecture de l'arrêt de
la chambre d'accusation qui vous rend
badra cette promesse la cour d'appel de
paris chambre d'accusation a rendu
l'arrêt dont la teneur suit la cour à
présent avoir délibéré considérant que
les pièces de l'instruction résulte les
faits suivants la victime mam'zelle
frugère micheline clotilde 23 ans
étaient étudiants inscrits à la faculté
de lettres de paris ayant des raisons de
se voir enceintes des oeuvres du sieur
castaing philippe elle fit procéder à un
examen par un laboratoire spécialisé
dont le résultat lui parvint le vendredi
3 décembre 1971 confirmant qu'elle était
en état de grossesse
désemparé la moselle fougères téléphona
à 9h45 à la nommer lussan gse langue
avec laquelle entretenait des rapports
d'amitié pour lui faire part de son état
et manifesté son intention de mettre fin
à ses jours
lussan et solange lui déclara qu'il
existait d'autres solutions et lui
suggéra de se renseigner auprès de ses
amis et connaissances
il semble que la base elf hiver est
suivi ce conseil ne manifestant plus
aucune intention de se suicider elle se
procura vers 15 heures un billet d'avion
pour londres puis elle retire à de sa
banque la somme de 3000 francs en six
billets de 500 francs
elle donne un certain nombre de coups de
téléphone notamment à ses parents qui
résident à dwayne nord ainsi que sur
castex qui se trouvait en voyage
professionnel à oslo norvège puis à
19h30
elle appela solange russe enlevée à son
domicile pour la prier de la compagnie à
une soirée qui était offerte ce même
jour par le sur papier jean robert l'a
fait du sort j'ai donné son accord
précisant toutefois qu'elle ne pourrait
arriver je le sur pâques et avant 23h
23h30 la noël fugère quant à elle arrive
à la soirée vers 21h tous les
témoignages concordent pour dire qu'elle
bu plus que de raison
à deux heures du matin tous les invités
est en partie le sieur pâquis jean
robert et ça sort ariane découvrir la
demoiselle frugère allongé sur un lit
apparemment sans connaissance la croyant
ivre morte
ils décidèrent de le ramener chez elle
vers 2h45
le matin du samedi 4 décembre 71 l'a
nommé lusanger déclarant avoir sonné en
vain à l'appartement de son amie c'est
ouvrir la porte par le concierge
c'est alors qu'ils trouvèrent le corps
de malgré ce revers est tendue sans vie
sur le ligne
l'autopsié devait apprendre qu'elle
aurait succombé vers 5h30 du matin à
l'ingestion d'une dose très élevés de
médicaments toxiques des levées dans du
whisky canadien
cette ingestion ayant dû se produire
environ cinq heures avant le décès soit
entre minuit et 1h dans la nuit du 3 au
4 décembre
l'enquète devait mettre en lumière les
faits suivants la noël frugère avait à
plusieurs reprises au cours de la
journée de la nuit précédant sa mort
manifesté une très grande appréhension à
l'idée de rencontrer solange lui ce but
changeait après lui avoir annoncé que
deux sur castex était son amant elle
n'ignorait pas de sentiments très vite
que la fille lui s'en émeuvent portait à
philippe castets et redoutait une action
violon de sa part il était de notoriété
publique que la moselle fusèrent suivait
un traitement médical et transportait
constamment dans son sac des médicaments
toxiques et dont jouer la pénombre qui
régnait dans l'appartement du sur papier
jean-robert ainsi que l'état d'ébriété
dans lequel se trouvait la demoiselle
sougères permettait à l'inculpé 200 fans
et de s'emparer facilement du sac de son
ami pour y subtiliser l'argent qui s'y
trouvaient ainsi que les médicaments
puis de lui faire absorber ces derniers
disent ou dans un verre d'alcool et fut
impossible malgré des recherches
minutieuses de retrouver les 3000 francs
en six billets de 500 francs
en revanche au cours d'une perquisition
effectuée au domicile de l'inculpé on
découvrit une somme de 3000 francs en
six billets de 500 francs dont elle fut
incapable de justifier l'origine dit que
les pièces et de l'instruction résulte
charges suffisantes contre lui son geste
selon j'ai 1000 yens
premièrement d'avoir à paris le 3 et 4
décembre 1971
en tout cas dans le ressort de la cour
d'assises qui l ont appris depuis moins
de dix ans donner volontairement la mort
la demoiselle frugère micheline clotilde
deuxièmement d'avoir à paris le 3 ou le
4 décembre 1971
en tout cas de recense dans la cour
d'assises siégeant à paris depuis temps
non prescrits soustrait frauduleusement
la somme de 3000 francs au préjudice de
la n'sele frugère crimes et délits
connexes prévus et réprimés par les
articles 231 jeu 300 2 304 319 à 401 du
code pénal prenons sa mise en accusation
de luçon vu sous l'angle et la renvoie
devant la cour d'assises siégeant à
paris pour y être jugé merci monsieur le
gars fier ça nagerait angèle avez-vous
vous habitiez avant notre arrestation 11
rue cap et à paris 17ème vous exerciez
la profession le programme e
vous êtes célibataire et vous n'avez
jamais été condamné l'actra duit devant
cette cour d'assises des chefs
d'homicides volontaires et de vols
qualifiés
vous êtes passible dans la mesure où
votre culpabilité serait établie de la
peine de mort vous avez été placé sous
mandat de dépôt et avait accompli à ce
jour un peu plus d'un an de prison
au titre de la détention provisoire
je vous rappelle que vous allez être
jugé aujourd'hui est que vous pouvez
vous exprimer librement
je vais maintenant vous interrogez est
tout d'abord sur votre vie jusqu'au
moment des faits votre père charles
l'usagé est agent d'installation dans
l'entreprise dirigée par monsieur
frugère le père de la victime
entreprise spécialisée dans l'épuration
des fumées agents l'installation en quoi
cela consiste-t-il exactement il va chez
les clients du thin pour installer les
systèmes d'épuration
il est donc un peu à faire de fréquents
déplacements oui le seul président à
bien votre mère jeanne but sow est
décédé en 1952 vous aviez alors trois
ans en 1955 vous êtes entré à liszt
l'institution sainte geneviève à douai
vous avez poursuivre vos études jusqu'au
baccalauréat
vous avez laissé le souvenir d'une élève
studieuse et appliquée vos résultats
scolaires ont été bons vous avez passé
le baccalauréat à l'âge de 17 ans avec
la mention bien vous est alors entré à
l'institut de programmation de
l'université de paris et après en avoir
obtenu le diplôme de fin d'études vous
avez été engagé comme programmeuse
d'applications par la société surf qui
vous employait encore au moment se
produisirent les faits qui vous sont
reprochés
qu'est ce que cela signifie programmeuse
d'application c'est un métier de
l'informatique
on prépare le travail des sorties nature
vous avez été nommé chef de section en
mars 71 et votre salaire à la date de
votre arrestation s'élevait à 2750
francs vous êtes la carte d'un studio
près de la porte champerret et vous
possédez une voiture
tout cela est exact c'est bien je vois
que en janvier 68
j'avais fait la connaissance d'un
certain jean jacques mauger rhin et
trois mois plus tard vous annonciez vos
fiançailles
mais en juillet de la même année à la
suite d'un voyage à bouaye en compagnie
de mon jardin
vous avez rompu ses fiançailles que
s'était il passé
rien de particulier je m'étais rendu
compte que nous n'étions pas c'est l'un
pour l'autre
c'est tout michel frugier n'at-elle pas
joué un rôle dans cette rupture
pas particulièrement pourtant il semble
que vous soyez disputé avec elle à cette
occasion une dispute assez vive m au
cours de laquelle vous lui avez lancé à
la tête un lourd cendrier de verre vous
avez également proféré des menaces
vous l'avez dit très exactement qui est
une ordure je te tuerai je n'ai pas
réfléchi
c'est en colère mais je ne pensais pas
ce que je disais oui enfin il ya quand
même eu le cendrier depuis quand
connaissiez-vous micheline fogel depuis
toujours nous avons pratiquement été
élevés ensemble vous entendiez bien avec
elle bien monsieur le président ce faux
toujours été très habile jusqu'à ce
michel fugère a fait elle aussi ses
études secondaires à l'institution
sainte geneviève étude beaucoup moins
brillante que les vôtres puisqu'elle
échoué deux fois au baccalauréat et de
leur tenue qu'en 1969 à 21 elle a alors
quitté doigts pour venir à paris où elle
a pris une inscription la faculté des
lettres
elle a à cette époque vécu quelques
temps chez vous n'est ce pas oui
monsieur le président pendant six mois
jusqu'à pâques de l'année suivante
six mois c'est long n'avez-vous pas j'ai
quelquefois le sentiment qu'elle abusait
de votre ami qui nous pourquoi votre
appartement était petit elle s'y est
installé comme chez elle c'est normal
cela fait ça vite et quelles étaient ses
moyens d'existence ne vous en at elle
pas pourtant emprunté à plusieurs
reprises bien
venons en maintenant à philippe castets
où et quand avez-vous fait sa
connaissance en 1970 c'est une étude
pour notre société nous nous sommes
rencontrés à la cafétéria
vous avez tout de suite sympathisé tout
de suite parce que le président nous
nous sommes revus nous sommes sortis
ensemble très souvent enfin
souvent c'était après que micheline
frugère quitter votre appartement
saviez vous monsieur castet chez vous
oui mais philippe ne jamais y que mon
amour en octobre de la même année vous
avez commencé à parler de lui comme de
votre fiancée vous deviez vous marier eh
bien je suppose que si je n'avais pas
été arrêté je suppose que nous le
serions marier malgré sa liaison avec
michel fugère vous saviez pourtant ils
se connaissaient ils voient qu'ils les
avaient présentés et bien
avez vous quelque chose à ajouter sur
votre vie non mesdames et messieurs les
jurés des questions qu'elle avait qu'un
général l'accusé peux tu nous dire à
combien se montent les sommes que lui
avait emprunté mademoiselle frugère
approximativement moins de 3000 francs
plus au total
plus vous êtes remboursé
souvent voulu le faire et puis elle a
oublié de nous excuser appartenait à un
milieu aisé
vos origines avoue sont beaucoup plus
modestes votre père est en quelque sorte
un contremaître
enfin disons un peu plus qu'un
contremaître
n'avez vous jamais souffert de cette
différence certainement pas à l'autre
question met bien je vais maintenant
vous interroger sur les faits qui vous
sont reprochés
que s'est il passé le vendredi 3
décembre 1971
micheline me téléphoner au bureau le
matin pour me dire qu'elle était
enceinte
le parrain s'est affolée elle m'a dit
qu'elle voulait se suicider vous at elle
dit qui était le père de l'enfant à
naître
non à aucun moment au cours de la
journée du 3 décembre elle ne vous a dit
que philippe castets et son amant non
monsieur le président
pourtant vous êtes vus à plusieurs
reprises oui nous sommes téléphoné
plusieurs fois j'ai déjeuné avec elle et
je suis retourné la voir le soir en
sortant de mon bureau
vers 6 heures elle nous a proposé de
l'accompagner une soirée que donner l'un
de ses amis à l'occasion de son 25e
anniversaire
oui parce que le président a voulu avait
précisé que vous ne pourriez pas y être
avant 23h30 pourquoi il fallait que sur
itunes
et puis je voulais me faire une mise en
plis à quelle heure est pour arriver à
cette soirée
je n'y suis pas allé
s'allonge du danger je vous en prie dit
la vérité le jury est là pour entendre
en tout à l'heure d'été moideen ou deux
fois deux personnes vous ont vu au cours
de cette réception
elles vous ont reconnu faisant
formellement identifié ces deux
personnes se trompent
monsieur le président je ne suis pas
allé à cette soirée pourtant vous aviez
sachs ait accepté l'invitation de jean
fugère
oui mais ensuite j'ai réfléchi à part
micheline je ne connaissais personne et
j'avais peur de m'ennuyer
qu'avez vous fait alors vous êtes resté
chez nous non je suis allé au cinéma
je voulais voir mort à venise mais
malheureusement vous n'avez pu donner
aucune indication aucune précision qui
permettent de vérifier l'exactitude de
vos déclarations le seul renseignements
qu'on ait pu recueillir concerne lors de
votre retour
un nouveau voisin a pu la big hill et
1h25 1h25 du matin les questions il à
messieurs jurés l'avocat général une
précision monsieur le président ma
cliente a indiqué aux enquêteurs le nom
du cinéma et le titre du film
malheureusement elle n'a pas gardé son
ticket
qu'il me soit permis de vous le demander
mesdames et messieurs les jurés
lorsque vous allez au cinéma gardez vous
toujours votre ticket d'entrée pour le
présenter le cas échéant la police je
suis d'accord avec vous mettrez charline
j'en suis ravie monsieur l'avocat
général l'accusé en effet à donner le
nom d'un cinéma proche de son domicile
le ministère public s'est renseigné ce
soir là la séance s'est terminée à 00h20
or la cuisine est rentrée chez elle qu'à
1h25
qu'at-elle fait entre temps cela dit l
instruction je me suis promené monsieur
le président voici une information
communiquée par la météorologie
nationale
au cours de la nuit du 3 au 4 décembre
d'abondantes chutes de neige se sont
produites sur toute la région parisienne
la températures relevées sous abri était
de -2 degrés un temps particulièrement
propice à la promenade
évidemment après mort à venise les jurés
à pression
mais charlie
non je suis le président j'ai
suffisamment d'éléments dans le dossier
pour ne pas chercher querelle à monsieur
l'avocat général sur des problèmes de
météorologie vous pouvez vous asseoir
nous allons maintenant entendre les
experts monsieur le professeur francis
leu dans le ciel professeurs ont juré de
rendre compte de vos recherches et
constatations à votre honneur et
conscience je le jure avec monsieur le
docteur quesnoy j'ai pratiqué l'autopsié
du cadavre de la nommer frugère
micheline décédé le 4 décembre 1971
le décès a été causée par l'absorption
massive entre minuit et une heure du
matin de trimer pranoi 25 médicaments un
usage psychiatrique dans la dose
mortelle est de 750 mg on peut évaluer
la dose absorbée à au moins 1 g 75 soit
plus du double de la dose mortelle
nous avons relevé à la surface du foie
des reins et du cerveau déçu fusion
hémorragique traduisent l'état
d'intoxication aiguë dans lequel se
trouvait la victime
par ailleurs l'examen de l'utérus et de
ses annexes a démontré l'existence d'une
grossesse d'environ sept semaines enfin
un prélèvement de sang au coeur a montré
à l'analyse chimique une alcoolémie
assez élevé d'un grand 35 par les
questions et dames et messieurs les
jurés monsieur l'avocat général la
défense la quoi vous remercie monsieur
le professeur monsieur le docteur
peyrieu
d'acteurs vous jurés de rendre compte de
vos recherches et constatations à votre
honneur et conscience je le jure
nous écoutons nous avons procédé le dr
octeville et moi-même aux examens
psychiatriques et médico psychologique
de la nommer lusanger solange il s'agit
d'une femme d'une intelligence
supérieure à la moyenne de contact
facile bien qu'assez fortement inspiré
verte' sa mère étant décédée alors
qu'elle était très jeune mais là dans
son enfance souffert d'une certaine
carence affective qu'elle a compensé par
une volonté de réussite dans ses études
et sa vie professionnelle
cette carence affective peut également
expliquer des réactions passionnelles
inattendu chez un sujet généralement
pondéré l'affectivité et marqué par une
nette tendance possessive et une nature
irritable supportant mal la
contradiction et ce sont là des traits
de caractère et non des déviations
psychique
en résumé l'adaptation sociale les
bonnes dans l'ensemble on ne relève
aucune anomalie mentale majeure et le
sujet est accessible à une sanction
pénale
docteur en juillet 1968 l'accusé avait
déjà menacé mademoiselle frugère de la
tuer et passant de la parole aux actes
elle avait tenté de la somme et avec un
lourd cendrier de verre interrogé au
sujet de ce geste
elle a déclaré avoir agi sans réfléchir
sous l'effet de la colère
cette explication vous paraît-il
acceptable un stress émotionnel violent
et certainement de nature à déclencher
en elle une pulsion agressive et
raisonnée traduit en bon français cela
veut il dire qu'elle est capable de tuer
dans un mouvement de colle
disons que ce n'est pas exclue oui c'est
très possible selon mercy d'auteur c'est
tout ce que je voulais savoir qu'est ce
qu'il en est
non monsieur le président je trouve que
l'on a déjà bien assez parlé d'un chef
d'une réaction tout à fait normal de la
part d'une jeune fille amoureuse
réaction qui n'a d'ailleurs eu aucune
suite
monsieur l'avocate générale jusqu'au 3
décembre 1971 en tout cas merci docteur
monsieur legrand
quels sont vos nom prénom âge profession
domicile le grand roger 47 ans
commissaire de police faisant élection
de domicile 9 boulevard du palais paris
4e vous jurer de parler sans haine et
sans crainte de dire toute la vérité
rien que la vérité devait la main droite
et dit dieu le veut je jure c'est votre
déposition si le commissaire le 4
décembre 1971 à 12h20 mission m'a été
donné par l'état major de la police
judiciaire de procéder à une enquête sur
le décès par mort violente de la nommer
frugère micheline je me suis rendu au
domicile de celle-ci et j ai rencontré
l'accusé ici présentes qui semblait très
émue par la mort de son ami elle m'a
déclaré que celle ci s'était
certainement suicider j'ai découvert
dans le sac de la victime trois flacons
de trimer pranoi 25 dont deux étaient
vides
par la suite l'enquète m'a appris que
micheline frugère avait passé la soirée
et une partie de la nuit précédant sa
mort chez des amis il y avait fait
preuve d'une grande agitation est fait
allusion à plusieurs reprises à une
vengeance dont elle craignait d'être la
victime
ces déclarations ainsi que la
disparition d'une somme de 3000 francs
en espèces que micheline frugère
transporter dans son sac ont amené
envisagée non plus l'hypothèse d'un
suicide et d'un meurtre j'ai donc fait
procéder à l'interrogatoire systématique
des 47 personnes ayant assisté à la
réception et j'ai appris ainsi que
micheline frugère avait nommément
désigné solange du danger comme étant la
personne dont elle redoutait la
vengeance le 10 décembre 1971 nous avons
effectué une perquisition au domicile de
solange du danger au cours de laquelle
nous avons découvert une somme de 3000
francs dont elle n'a pu nous indiquer
l'origine avec précision considérant
alors qu'il existait contre elle de
graves présomptions gémissent allant du
danger à la disposition de monsieur le
substitut de la section criminelle sous
la prévention d'homicide volontaire
et vol des questions mesdames et
messieurs les jurés ce que l'avocat
général la défense le témoin peut-il
nous dire si la victime était connue des
services de police avant le 4 décembre
1971 au mois d'avril de la même année un
car de police secours a été appelé pour
transporter micheline frugère d'urgence
à l'hôpital necker pardon à la suite
d'un accident de la voie publique non
d'une tentative de suicide
mais voilà qui est très intéressant
micheline fraser avait donc déjà tenté
de mettre fin à ses jours
autrement dit malgré les conclusions de
votre enquête monsieur le commissaire
l'hypothèse d'un suicide demeure fondée
merci monsieur le commissaire vous
pourrez rejoindre votre service
les pièces à conviction numéros 1 2 et 3
ce sont les flacons de médicaments
ces trois missions on a trouvé chez vous
qu'est ce que c'était mais de l'argent
j'entends bien mais d'où venaient-ils
c'était des économies vous n'avez pas de
compte en banque des chèques postaux
alors pourquoi garder vos une telle
somme chez vous pourrez savoir sous la
mer en cas de besoin 3000 francs en cas
de besoin en billets de 500 francs des
billets neufs monsieur président dont
les numéros se suivent exactement comme
si quelqu'un venait de retirer ou du
segment des mois suivants monsieur
philippe castets
quels sont vos nom prénom âge profession
domicile gasté philip 31 ans ingénieur
en esthétique industrielle 71 rue manin
plaisir etes-vous par antoyé avec
l'accusé était là votre service et vous
aux siens mon monsieur président la
connaissiez vous avant les faits oui
vous jurer de parler sans haine et sans
crainte de dire toute la vérité rien que
la vérité leur aide à main droite et 10
du lun je jure au début décembre 1971
j'étais en voyage d'affaires à oslo le
vendredi 3 décembre en fin d'après-midi
micheline frugère m'a téléphoné à mon
hôtel et manon cm annoncé qu'elle était
enceinte elle m'a dit qu'elle avait
réfléchi et qu'elle allait faire un le
nécessaire je lui ai répondu que c'était
une imbécillité je lui ai interdit
formellement
j'étais responsable je devais l'épouser
elle m'a dit qu'elle en avait parlé à
solange qui était sa meilleure amie mais
sans lui annoncer que j'étais le père je
vais demander de faire la tergiversé en
disant que solange serait folle de
jalousie et qu'elle était capable de la
tuer je lui ai répondu que c'était de
l'enfantillage et je lui ai demandé de
le faire sans délai elle a fini par
comprendre et m'a promis de lui
téléphoner aussitôt que nous aurons
raccrocher voilà tout ce que je sais
vous les épouses et mademoiselle frugère
l'aimiez vous les sentiments n'avait
rien à voir dans cette affaire
l'auriez vous épousez s'il n'avait pas
été enceintes non micheline n'était pas
le genre femme avec qui j'aimerais faire
ma vie elle nous a quand même pas
empêché d'en faire votre maîtrise sa
nage usagers était-elle au courant de
votre liaison non seulement j'étais très
jalouse et micheline préféré qu'ils ne
sachent pas et vous avez accepté de ne
rien me dire
je savais que cette aventure n'aurait
qu'un temps j'aime bien solange j'aime
beaucoup selon j'allais me paraissent
est inutile de la faire souffrir son
raison des pics en est la connaissez
vous près de trois ans elle vous êtes
très attaché vous l'ignorez pas avant
votre liaison être micheline frugère at
il été question de mariage entrevue
normand n'a pas été prononcé c'est pas
la peine nous le comprenions nous sommes
souvent sortis ensemble
on m'avait rendait au théâtre
cancer
vous pouvez présenter à vos amis
filet
j'aime votre intelligence solange j'ai
beaucoup d'affection pour vous mais
je vous demande pardon sauvage
pardon à moins
y'a pas de raison j'aurais dû comprendre
j'ai peur d'avoir été ridicule
merci de me vanter la vérité philippe
sun dont nous venons d'être les témoins
a bouleversé ma cliente tout le monde le
comprendra
je voudrais poser une question à
monsieur philippe castets qui est
certainement celui qui connaît le mieux
solange lusanger monsieur castet
croyez-vous solange des anges est
capable d'avoir tué micheline ce projet
pas un instant
merci monsieur des mois suivants madame
votre panier
quels sont vos nom prénom âge profession
domicile votre barrier eliane nero l'est
35 ans 42 recapet paris 17ème
programmeuse ni par anthony allié avec
la cuisine n'est pas à votre service
vous n'êtes pas aux siens non la
connaissiez vous avant les faits aux
jurés de parler sans haine et sans
crainte de dire toute la vérité rien que
la vérité levé la main droite et d'idiot
le suggère le vendredi 3 décembre 1971
loiselle lusanger m'a téléphoné vers
19h45 le soir pour me demander de lui
prêter une robe ça m'a étonné parce que
nous sommes collègues de bureau enfin
pas particulièrement intime
le lendemain matin c'était samedi à 11
heures du matin
elle est venue me rapporter la robe je
lui ai demandé si elle avait passé une
bonne soirée
elle m'a répondu que oui très bonne
pourquoi est ce madame vous le parier
que vous avez emprunté une robe ce
qu'ils habitent près de chez moi
nous savons à peu près la même taille
allez vous remarqué quelque chose
d'inhabituel dans l'attitude de solange
lusanger quand elle est venue chercher
là oui monsieur le président elle
paraissait très énervé comme si elle
venait d'apprendre une chose qui l'avait
contrarié mauvaise nouvelle elle n'avait
pas du tout l'air d'une personne qui se
réjouit d'aller à une soirée des
questions mesdames et messieurs les
jurés
monsieur l'avocat général vous nous avez
dit madame
va ressentir l'impression que l'accusé
avait appris une mauvaise nouvelle
supposer qu'un moment plutôt l ai appris
que l'homme qu'elle aimait avait un
amant avait une maîtresse pardon qu'il
allait l'épouser
ne pensez vous que la révélation de cet
état de chose de suffit à provoquer
l'énervement dont vous parlez ça peut
peut-être monsieur madame vous
travaillez avec l'accusé vous devez donc
bien la connaître
tu pensez vous d'elle sa moralité il n'y
a rien à en dire
enfin pour autant que je sache je n'aime
pas dire du mal des gens mais elle
n'était pas très aimé au bureau elle ne
parlait pas aux collègues elle était
très fier lui arrive-t-il de se mettre
en colère
souvent nous ont rarement a été plutôt
du genre sur noir si vous voyez voyons
très bien madame je vous remercie
mais deux petites précisions j'aimerais
que le témoin nous rappelle sa
profession prendre à mons et son âge 35
ans je connais mal l'organigramme de
l'entreprise qui vous emploie mais je
crois savoir que le service du personnel
de l'informatique est divisé en sections
n'est ce pas c'était elle qui était
votre chef de section avec un salaire
sensiblement plus élevé que le vôtre
bien qu'elle soit de 11 ans votre
cadettes dont je voulais simplement
faire remarquer à la cour que l'envié la
jalousie étant des sentiments très
humain le témoignage de mme alain vaute
barrier risque d'être entachée d'une
certaine partialité
merci la kobo merci madame témoin
suivant
je suis paquet quels sont vos nom prénom
âge profession domicile jean-robert
paquet 26 ans urbanistes 37 rue massenet
paris xvième où j'irai de parler sans
haine et sans crainte de dire toute la
vérité rien que la vérité levé la main
droite et jure je te jure je vais
inviter des amis pour mon anniversaire
mais je suis est arrivé vers 9h elle m'a
dit bonjour et elle m'a prévenu qu'il
avait invité une de ses amies qui devait
arriver un peu plus tard je ne me suis
pas spécialement occupé d'elle saut vers
11h je lui demandais si son ami était
arrivé m'a dit que non pas encore car
nous avons bavardé et elle m'a annoncé
qu'elle était enceinte et que la lette
épouse et philippe castets ce philippe
castets c'était et un de ses amis que
j'avais vu une ou deux fois avec lequel
je n'avais pas sympathisé alors je lui
dis qu'à mon avis elle allait faire une
bêtise s'est mise à pleurer
elle m'a dit qu'elle était foutue
qu'elle n'avait plus qu'à se suicider de
toute façon s'il ne se trouvait pas
quelqu'un d'autre s'en charger à sa
place et je l' ai plus revus jusqu'à 2
heures du matin à ce moment là je les
trouvais étendu sur un lit
il y avait un verre vide à côté d'elle
j'ai cru qu'elle était ivre morte ça lui
arrivait souvent tout le monde était
parti j'ai appelé ma soeur arias nous
l'avons ramené chez elle
et puis le lendemain j'ai appris même
les neiges phrygien n'at-elle pas à un
moment donné ouvert son sac devant vous
assure oui j'oubliais quand elle m'a
parlé de philippe castel m'a montré des
photos qui étaient dans son portefeuille
et j'ai remarqué qu'il avait beaucoup
d'argent
les billets de 500 francs combien 5,6
c'est possible
savez-vous acquis mademoiselle frugère
faisait allusion lors quand elle vous a
dit que si elle ne se situait pas
quelqu'un s'en chargerait à sa place oui
à son amie seul anges vous souvenez vous
des termes qu'il a employés exactement
ce qu'il a dit après la vacherie que je
lui ai fait elle est capable de me tuer
cela ne vous a pas inquiété
vous savez micheline fallait en prendre
et en laisser
elle est même bien sont intéressantes il
ya deux ans presque 3 elle avait fait
semblant de se suicider semblant et
devions aller au cinéma toute la bande
il avait demandé qu'on vient de
l'apprendre chez elle elle avale et seth
rogen demi heure avant donc elle savait
bien qu'on arrive on attend votre avis
pourquoi tel fait cela uniquement pour
se rendre intéressant dont il devait
bien avoir autre chose elle crâne est
comme ça mais au fond c'était une bof il
n'a jamais été heureuse et ses parents
ne l'aimé pas
pouvez vous nous dire si salon gisant à
g est venu chez vous le vendredi 3
décembre
non je ne sais pas dont la porte était
ouverte on entrait on sortait les amis
des amis enfin des gens que j'avais
jamais vu qui avait très peu de lumière
et comme je ne la connaissais pas vous
la connaissiez pas et si une fusion ne
vous l'avez jamais présenté non voilà
vais parler d'al quelquefois en disant
que c'était la fille d'un ouvrier de son
père le voyait de temps en temps comme
ça
vous avez déclaré avoir amené michel
fugère chez elle vous possédiez la clé
de son appartement
non je te prise dans son sac
avez vous remarqué s'il y avait des
flacons de médicaments dans son sac
oui j'ai même remarqué qu'ils étaient
vides fin de et puis je me suis demandé
pourquoi elle ne les avait pas acheter
mesdames et messieurs les jurés l'avocat
général la défense merci monsieur témoin
suivant
mademoiselle papier
quels sont vos nom prénom âge profession
domicile arienne pâquis et 23 ans
étudiante 37 rue massenet paris 16e aux
jurés de parler sans âme et sans crainte
de dire toute la vérité rien que la
vérité levé la main droite et des viols
sur jalle jir du tout ce qui s'est passé
au cours de la soirée du vendredi 3
décembre 1971 bien ce soit là nous
avions une réception à la maison et vers
11h15 mais gêne était complètement saoul
enfin livre j'ai pas compris la moitié
de ce qu'elle me raconte elle parlait d'
fonds dynamique voulait l'assassiner
elle voulait se suicider enfin moi j'ai
pensé que c'était du roman comme
d'habitude
et puis vers 2 heures du matin tout le
monde était parti alors j'ai essayé de
ranger un petit peu et jean robert m'a
appelé mais chine était ivre mort couché
sous le lit nos parents heureusement il
n'était pas là alors on l'a ramené chez
elle
vous at elle parlé de la nuit qui
voulaient l'assassiner
oui
vous at elle dit son nom oui c'était
solange du sang chez vous connaissiez
solange les engins
non
non mais chine ont parlé quelques fois
mais c'était toujours pour se moquer
d'elle elle disait qu'elle ne savait
pasqua fait qu'elle était alors qu'elle
était avec mal fagotée fin des choses
comme ça quoi
en fait j'ai souvent eu l'impression
qu'elle était beaucoup plus liées que
micheline voulait bien le dire
simplement je crois qu'elle avait un peu
honte de sonner
pouvez vous me dire si solange l'usagé
est venu chez vous à la soirée du 3
décembre
l instruction quand on nous a confronté
oui oui il m'a semblé l'avoir vu à la
maison
et maintenant je veux maintenant
maintenant j'en suis pas sûr je sais pas
des questions mesdames et messieurs les
jurés chez le général la défense merci
mademoiselle témoin suivant un recul sur
l'instruction
je jure un instant nous payer nous
indiquer d'abord vos nom prénom âge
profession domicile isabelle belfond 23
ans étudiante de square fontenelle
neuilly sur seine le pi parentignat lié
avec la cuisine elle n'est pas à votre
service ou n'êtes pas aux siens vous ne
la connaissiez pas avant les faits vous
jurer de parler sans haine et sans
crainte de dire toute la vérité rien que
la vérité levé la main droite et dit je
le jure je le jure qu'est-ce que je dois
dire ce que vous avez remarqué au cours
de la soirée et de la nuit du 3 au 4
décembre 1971
micheline était complètement saoul
encore plus que d'habitude
et pourtant c'était pas la première fois
elle racontait des choses quel genre de
choses
d'abord elle a raconté qu'elle était
fiancée qu'elle allait se marier mais
alors ensuite on ça n'allait plus du
tout elle disait qu'elle voulait se
suicider il faut dire qu'elle était
plutôt cyclothymique
en pleine euphorie et puis cinq minutes
après plus personne
elle avait des médicaments dans son sac
elle les montre est souvent en disant
quand j'en aurai trop marre up micheline
nous ça nous fait plutôt rire depuis le
temps on n'y croyait plus beaucoup donné
vous en aux faits sur lesquels vous
devez déposer le buzz
la soirée chez jean robert vers minuit
et demi je sais pas exactement
j'ai vu micheline
dans un coin du living room avec elle
j'ai peur d'un disque elle disait mais
elle avait l'air de chamailler les
questions et l'inde et messieurs les
jurés monsieur l'avocat général net
la déposition du témoin ci précise que
j'hésite à lui poser des questions
mademoiselle belfond informellement
reconnais ma cliente reconnu dans le mot
reconnu il y à connaître le témoin
connaissait donc selon ge lusanger avant
cette soirée
répondez à une mazel alors comment avez
vous fait pour la reconnaître
je l'ait reconnu après quand la police
me l'a montré
donc vous aviez déjà vu son visage c'est
monsieur jean robert bacchi wii tient
pourtant les éclairages été très réduits
ces deuxièmes répondait la cour moselle
admettons pourquoi vous ayez pu
l'identifier vous avez sans doute été
frappé par certains détails la coiffure
de mademoiselle lusanger par exemple oui
elle avait les cheveux auburn avec la
raie sur le côté mais surtout j'ai
remarqué sa robe
comment est elle cette robe assez courte
mais de quelle couleur marron glacé
pièces à conviction numéro de carte
ça une seconde m avez vous noté quelque
chose de particulier à propos de cette
robe
oui elle avait une ceinture dorée avec
un empiècement sur le devant c'était une
robe en jersey une robe chasuble plutôt
joli et lorsque vous avez été confronté
à un client dans les locaux de la police
elle portait cette même robe
oui si je comprends bien si je comprends
bien c'est grâce à cette robe que vous
l'avez reconnue bien sûr puisque je ne
l'avais jamais vu avant en somme ce
n'est pas ma cliente que vous avez
reconnu mais la rendent monsieur le
président c'est une requête à formuler
je vous demande en vertu de votre
pouvoir discrétionnaire d'entendre un
témoin non cités mais qui se trouve
présentement dans cette salle s'agit de
la demoiselle marchese l'avocat général
par des flexions si l'audition de ce
témoin dernière minute peut éclairer la
cour est vicié veuillez appeler
mademoiselle mart aisée
quelles sont vous pouvez vous retirer
moselle belfond allez vous asseoir
quels sont vos nom prénom âge profession
domicile gisèle marchese 26 ans
traductrice interprète à l'unesco
17 rue de landrecies à suresnes loisel
nous entendrons en vertu de mon pouvoir
discrétionnaire mais à titre de simples
renseignements et sans goût prêté
serment m je vous laisse le soin
d'interroger les témoins demoiselles
voulez-vous dire à la cour si vous
assistiez le 3 décembre 1971 à la soirée
offerte par jean-robert papier oui
comment étiez-vous coiffé comme
aujourd'hui comment étiez-vous vêtu je
portais la même europe aujourd'hui
avez vous remarqué c'est quelqu'un ce
soir là portait une robe identique à la
vôtre non je n'ai pas remarqué
merci monsieur le président je pense que
cette déposition ramène à sa juste
valeur le témoignage de mademoiselle
belfond qui a seulement reconnu ma
cliente à la robe qu'elle portait au -
dessus celle de mademoiselle marchese
nous elmer these avez vous eu l'occasion
au cours de cette soirée de vous
entretenir avec micheline frugère
naturellement nous nous connaissions
bien vous êtes vous disputé avec elle
avec micheline non non il n'y avait pas
de raison
renaud denne pouvez vous affirmer que
personne au cours de cette soirée ne
portait une robe non pas identique à la
ventre mais qui n'est d'autre point
commun que la couleur et une vague
ressemblance dans la forme telle que
celle là je pense que je leur ai
remarqué vous le pensiez vous en êtes
sûr je le pense autrement dit vous
n'êtes pas sur l'accusé pouvait donc se
trouver chez jean robert paquet sans que
vous l'ayez remarqué
je vous remercie mademoiselle d'elf on
va y revenir à la barre
regardez bien ces d'europe
maintenez-vous que l'accusé portait
l'une d'elles à la soirée du 3 décembre
oui laquelle celle ci avec la ceinture
dorée vous savez que de votre déposition
dépend peut-être la liberté et la vie
d'une femme
je sais où mais maintenant oui l oise et
le papier voulez vous revenir à la barre
l'une des personnes présentes à la
soirée du 3 décembre portait la robe qui
est sur cette table
où
je sais pas
c'est plus c'est plus merci mademoiselle
monsieur fruits
j'ai super
c'est plus
c'est plus merci mademoiselle monsieur
frugère
quels sont vos nom prénom âge profession
domicile robert fruges et à 48
industriel nov avenue du président
arsham doigt ou je répare les sens et
n'est sans crainte de dire toute la
vérité rien que la vérité levé la main
droite et des dieux je le jure monsieur
vous êtes le père de la victime
que s'est il passé le 3 décembre 1971
encore maintenant je n'arrive pas à
comprendre ma fille micheline m'a
téléphoné à mon bureau dans l'après midi
ses propos étaient assez incohérent
elle m'a parlé dans nuit sans préciser
lesquelles elle aurait voulu nous
rencontrer elle souhaitait que nous
venions à paris ma femme et moi je lui
ai dit que c'était impossible alors elle
a proposé de venir à douelle
malheureusement nous étions invités en
belgique dans une partie de chasse oui
un de mes clients les plus importants
avaient organisé une partie pour moi il
m'était très difficile de ne pas y
assister
j'ai proposé à micheline de lui envoyer
un chèque
elle vous l'avez demandé non mais en
général quand on a des ennuis
elle a d'ailleurs refusé
alors nous avons bavardé encore quelques
instants et puis on m'a appelé sur une
autre rue sur une autre ligne j'ai
raccroché
c'est la dernière fois que j'ai entendu
ça va vous n'avez pas d'autre enfant je
crois non j'aurais voulu un fils mais
pour la santé de ma femme les médecins
nous ont interdit sa cause de la santé
de votre femme que vous aviez pris une
gouvernante pour élever micheline huy
micheline est une enfance très difficile
très accaparante elle aurait voulu qu'on
s'occupe d'elle toute la journée mais je
suis obligé de consacrer beaucoup de
temps à mes affaires et ma femme de
santé fragile elle doit suivre des cures
plusieurs fois dans l'année
en avril 71 votre fille micheline a
tenté de se donner la mort oui je l' ai
appris seulement autour de l' enquête
sur le moment je n'en est rien si
micheline ne nous l'a pas dit
sans cela vous pensez bien
qu'auriez vous fait
je ne sais pas je lui aurais sans doute
proposé de revenir à la maison
sa mère se serait occupé jeunes vous
connaissez l'accusé oui très bien
son père est à 2 mais plus anciens
collaborateurs
c'est un homme d'une conscience
professionnelle comme on n'en rencontre
pas souvent mais je lis née solange
était 13ème goulard ces vielles chez
vous assez rarement
je dois le reconnaître cela aurait pu
créer une situation embarrassante pour
elle bien entendu ces questions mesdames
et messieurs les jurés l'avocat général
monsieur vous nous avez dit
qu'aujourd'hui encore vous ne compreniez
pas pourtant un scan incident ne vous
avait pas déjà mené en juillet 1968 à
mettre en doute cette amitié exemplaire
que l'accusé profession pour votre fille
en juillet 68 l'histoire mon gérant
ça a été une affaire lamentable
la petite solange était venu à la maison
nous présenter un garçon avec lequel
elle était fiancée et il a fallu que ma
fille s'amourache vêtements de lui tout
le monde savait que ce ne serait qu'un
feu de paille
mais selon j'appris cela très mal elle
est venue à la maison nous faire une
scène très pénible elle menaçait ma
fille et j'ai été obligé de la priés de
sortir alors elle a saisi un cendrier et
l'a lancée en direction de micheline
elle l'a blessé évidemment c'était à
pavés de verre très lourd on a dû lui
vers plusieurs points de suture
le témoin peut-il nous dire si sa fille
à considérer ce geste comme une
tentative de meurtre ou comme la
réaction un peu vive d'une personne
blessée dans ses sentiments
en vérité micheline avait des torts elle
s'était conduite d'une façon très
inélégant tel le savez en a pas tenu
rigueur à solange de son acte et si bien
signifier manière
les approcher madame
quels sont vos nom prénom âge profession
domicile suzanne fugère 45 ans sans
profession 9 avenue du président chamdo
et aux jurés de parler sans haine et
sans crainte de dire toute la vérité
rien que la vérité levé la main droite
et dit tu le fais le jir
pourquoi
pourquoi avez vous fait ça ça me faisait
me en tous
la cour remercie vous pouvez vous
retirer une à l'homme monsieur le
docteur farce
quels sons dont le nom prénom âge
profession domicile pendant le déchoir
ses 48 ans docteur en médecine 21 rue
des ciseaux paris 6e etes-vous parentois
lié avec la cuisine est elle à votre
service et vous aux siens non la
connaissiez vous avant les faits non aux
jurés de parler sans haine et sans
crainte de dire toute la vérité rien que
la vérité levé la main droite et jure m
à charles ives le témoin est incitée par
la défense je vous laisse le soin de
l'interroger docteur vous êtes
psychiatre vous avez suivi mademoiselle
frugère de juillet 1970 mais
renseignements sont exacts jusqu'à sa
mort pouvez vous préciser à la cour sans
trahir le secret professionnel à la
nature des soins que vous lui avait
prodigué moselle frégère souffrait de
mélancolie dépressive autrement dit tout
et pression nerveuse
si vous voulez on a souvent parlé au
cours de ces débats de ces sautes
d'humeur à témoin a même parlé de cyclos
petit nid oui oui c'est tout à fait
normal
nous les états dépressifs entraîne des
désordres caractériel et des troubles de
l'humeur alternativement dans le sens de
l'abattement et dans celui de
l'excitation
c'était le cas de mademoiselle frugère
qui présentait un terrain psychologique
extrêmement sensible certainement depuis
la première en france
si sa famille avait eu à son égard une
attitude plus ferme plus protectrice
l'évolution aurait été toute différente
malheureusement elle été laissée un peu
à l'abandon
je ne pense pas trahir le secret
professionnel en rappelant c'était autre
chose dans ma maladie ne faisait pas
mystère et qui était connue de tous ses
amis
le docteur lui avis vous prescrit du tri
mais pas dans le 25
oui n'est ce pas un médicament qui
présente un certain danger
essentielle oui bien sûr
toute médaille a son revers l'arsenal de
la chimiothérapie neuroleptiques et
antidépressives s'est considérablement
enrichie au cours des dix dernières
années
nous possédons maintenant des armes
d'une très grande efficacité
à condition toutefois de respecter la
posologie évidemment sinon sinon bien
sinon tout peut arriver
docteur ès avec l'une des ces drogues
moselle frugère avait déjà tenté de se
suicider en avril 1971
non pas exactement de toute façon je ne
pense pas que l'intention suicidaire et
était réel et pourquoi parce qu'elle
n'est pas morte
non parce qu'elle n'a pas agi comme
quelqu'un qui voulait mourir et le 3
décembre 1971
pensez vous que l'intention était réel
on vous savez mettre en matière de taux
10 ans fin de suicide il est bien
difficile d'émettre un jugement
définitif
le docteur je vais vous poser avec
brutalité la question laquelle m et
charles ives aimerait vous entendre
répondre
pouvez-vous affirmer à la cour que dans
la nuit du 3 au 4 décembre 1971
mademoiselle frugère n'a pas été victime
d'un meurtre
comme nous avons toutes raisons de
croire mais qu'elle s'est volontairement
et délibérément donné la mort comment
voulez vous je répondre à une telle
question
c'est impossible décidément m et charles
ives n'a pas de chance avec les témoins
qu'il a fait citer d'autres questions
mais n'osent guère et moi sinon monsieur
lusanger
quels sont vos nom prénom âge profession
domicile lusanger charles 52 ans agent
d'installation 35 à citer clair blanc
gilles doigts
monsieur vous êtes le père de l'accusé à
ce titre vous ne pouvez déposer sous
serment
la cour vous entendra donc à titre de
simples renseignements oui monsieur le
président ne sais pas quoi vous dire
monsieur le président je n'ai eu que des
satisfactions avec solange elle
travaillait bien elle était gentille
non vraiment je ne comprends pas
pourquoi elle a fait ça
vous croyez que votre fille écoutable
monsieur bien sûr que non elle n'est pas
coupable
et quand je la vois là si on l'y amener
c'est qu'il ya une raison
connaissiez la victime oui très bien
monsieur le président micheline venait
souvent à la maison
et selon je l'aidais à faire cette voie
elle travaillait si bien qu'elles
étaient leurs relations
micheline la ramenait bien un petit peu
vous comprenez monsieur le président
elle avait tout ce qu'elle voulait de
l'argent de poche des jolies robes elle
se moquait souvent de selongey disant
qu'elle était mal habillé qu'elle
n'était pas coquette mais selon ge s'en
fichait saluer ses gammes et puis
c'était vrai elle n'a jamais été très
coquette seul enjeu mesdames et
messieurs les jurés
c'est l'avocat général nous suggère g
vous souvenez vous d'une poupée que vous
aviez à faire teint clair la soeur de
l'accusé à l'occasion d'un anniversaire
je crois ah oui
que s'est il passé exactement j'ai
oublié
vous avez déclaré au magistrat
instructeur seul ans j'étais jalouse
elle voulait que sa soeur lui donne la
poupée elle s'est mise dans une colère
terrible qui m'a fait peur elle a
arraché méthodiquement les bras et les
jambes de la poupée comme s'il voulait
lui faire mal claire pleurait mais selon
ge continue et c'est bien ainsi que ça
s'est passé
ce vent merci monsieur le président
j'aimerais que les témoins précise l'âge
qu'avait solange à l'époque où s'est
déroulé ce drame affreux je pense sept
ans non sept ans et demi
évidemment les colères d'une enfant de 7
ans et demi sont la preuve d'un
caractère jaloux et violent qui la
conduira inéluctablement quelques vingt
ans plus tard devant une cour d'assises
à quoi vous remercie monsieur
est ce parce qu'il met
je suis président ma cliente désirait
faire une déclaration
nous vous écoutons c'est au sujet des
3000 francs je préfère dire la vérité
des prix
ce sont les billets qu'on a retrouvé
chez vous oui mais je les ai pas volé
micheline meules et devait depuis des
mois elle me devais même beaucoup plus
que ça loiselle fugère vous at elle
remis ses billets elle-même n'ont donc
c'est un vol
nul n'a le droit de se faire justice soi
même quand les allées vous dérober le
c'est évident au cours de la soirée en
même temps du médicament on sait pas
vrai samedi matin après avoir appelé la
police du concierge est étendue pour les
attendre de voir la porte
j'étais seul dans l'appartement où s'est
ouvert le sac de micheline pour voir si
elle avait pas laissé une lettre d'adieu
ou quelque chose comme ça j'ai vu les
billets alors c'est une somme et
biechlin me devais de l'argent depuis si
longtemps c'est tout vous n'avez rien a
ajouté l'avocat général vous avez la
parole pour vos réquisitions
monsieur le président messieurs de la
cour mesdames et messieurs les jurés
tout au long de ce débat je me suis
demandé quel concours de circonstances
avait amené cette jeune fille à
commettre le crime pour lequel vous
allez la juge que nous ont dit les
experts qu'elle est très intelligente
ambitieuse et c'est tout à son honneur
mais elle est aussi jalouse violente
renfermé introverti 10 ce même expert
ses collègues de bureau ne l'aiment pas
on la trouve fier sournoise elle avait
une amie d'enfance micheline frugère
en ce n'était pas une simple micheline
frugère persuadé que la fortune de ses
parents lui donner tous les droits
notamment celui de considérer solange d
angers comme son bien comme sa chose
n'est-il pas la fille d'un employé de
son père alors le soir après l'école
comme et les mauvais élèves selon jll
aide à faire ses devoirs
plus tard elle a 20 ans et c'est déjà
une femme elle s'amuse à séduire le
fiancé de solange quand elle vient paris
elle s'installe chez solange pendant des
mois comme en terrain conquis
si le chèque paternel tarder à arriver
elle emprunte de l'argent à solange et
lorsque celle ci lui demande de la
rembourser bien
et n'oublie voilà une amitié bien
encombrante mais solange ne dit rien
elle sait que micheline a honte de se
montrer en sa compagnie qu'elle se moque
d'elle répétant partout qu'elle est
laide qu'elle ne sait pas quoi fait
qu'elle est mal fagoté mais cela ne dit
toujours rien
elle accepte tout simplement au fil des
mois et des années à mesure que les
vexations se multiplient sa rancoeur
grandi si naturelle et son amitié pour
micheline se transforme peu à peu en un
sentiment tout différent là elle dit on
n'est facilement de l'amour de l'amitié
aussi est ce l'enjeu mais haïr micheline
frugère mais toujours sans est à dire
sans le montrer
et puis arrive ce mois de décembre 1971
seul engin monal elle sans croiser mais
elle forme des projets d'avenir songe au
mariage est brusquement c'est le coup de
tonnerre
elle découvre que celui là aussi
micheline le lui a volé elle attend un
enfant de lui il va l'épouser
cette fois c'en est trop ça explose
fait place à la vengeance cette
vengeance hélas nous savons quelle forme
et la prise le meurtre de micheline
frugère au soir du 3 décembre 1971
comment se défend l'accusé face aux
charges qui pèsent sur elle dans de la
façon la plus simple
elle nie tout en bloc pour commencer
elle n'est pas allée à cette soirée qui
le dit elle et elle seule les témoins
eux affirment le contraire
madame bovary est d'abord à qui elle a
emprunté une robe précisément pour se
rendre à cette soirée
mais surtout mademoiselle belfond
mademoiselle belle fougue qu'il a vu
qu'il a reconnu qu'il a identifié
formellement
malgré les efforts de la défense pour
semer le doute dans son esprit et dans
le vôtre
cette histoire de robe marron glacé et
la confusion qu'elle aurait pu commettre
eh bien non isabelle belfond maintient
son témoignage c'est bien la robe
emprunter un madame votre barrier
qu'elle a remarqué
elle a reconnu la ceinture dorée elle
les a vus le 3 décembre chez jean robert
bacchi que nous dit-on encore
micheline s'est suicidé
rien d'étonnant cela elle avait souvent
menacé de le faire elle montrait les
médicaments un véritable poison qui
était dans son sac 10 ans et répétant
partout qu'un jour elle les avalerait
elle le disait mais elle ne le faisait
pas c'était une attitude une façon on
vous l'a dit de se rendre intéressante
une sorte de jeu qu'elle poussait le
plus loin possible
elle était allée en avril 1971 jusqu'à
un simulacre de suicide
non ce n'était pas dangereux des amis à
l' arrivée elle ne savait pourquoi
brusquement ce soir là aurait-il mis sa
menace à exécution il se serait telle
donnée la mort parce qu'elle était
enceinte
certainement pas l'accusé nous l'a dit
elle même si le matin me semblait
désemparé l'après midi elle avait
retrouvé son attitude de tous les jours
parce que philippe castets voulait
l'épouser
alors dont on ne se tue pas parce qu'un
homme vous demande en mariage et on ne
tue pas non plus parce qu'un ami vous
dis qu'on n'est pas fait pour effet un
bébé ni pour tricoter en attendant leur
tour de son mari non micheline frugère
n'avait aucune raison de se suicider qui
alors a fait dissoudre les comprimés de
trimer pranoi dans un verre d'alcool
mais nous le savons la victime l'a
répété je ne sais combien de fois
pendant la soirée
elle sera folle de jalousie elle voudra
me tuer elle est capable de m'assassiner
et ce nom ce nom qui revient constamment
sur ses lèvres
solange challenge qui une fois déjà ne
l'oublions pas a tenté de la tuer en
avril 1968 à doué et dans les mêmes
circonstances alors que miss chine
venait de lui arracher l'homme qu'elle
aimait non
solange du temps je n'en était pas à son
coup d'essai quand elle a tué micheline
frugère le 3 décembre 1971
car elle n'a tué elle a tué deux fois et
la mère et l'enfant
micheline était enceinte nous avons
tendance à l'oublier
est ce un crime passionnel
un de ces crimes commis à chaud par une
femme qui découvre qu'elle est trompé et
qui abat sa rivale sous l'effet d'une
émotion intense d'une fureur aveugle qui
n'arrive pas à se contrôler pas du tout
il y a dans le crime de cette femme
quelque chose de froid de méthodique de
calculer qui fait peur à 19h30 le 3
décembre
micheline frugère lui téléphone sur le
conseil de philippe casté pour lui
annoncer que celui ci est le père de son
enfant
car c'est bien à ce moment là que le lui
a dit rappelez-vous le témoignage de
madame volts barrier quand l'accusé
vient chez elle pour emprunter une robe
elle est très énervé comme si elle
venait d'apprendre une mauvaise nouvelle
elle n'avait pas du tout l'air de
quelqu'un qui se réjouit d'aller à une
soir alors pourquoi tu as accepté d'y
aller à cette soirée
mais parce qu'elle sait qu'il y aura
beaucoup de monde
qu'on ne fera pas attention elle
d'ailleurs personne ne la connaît
peut-on rêver circonstances plus
favorables
et c'est là c'est là qu'apparaît toute
l'horreur du geste
à 7h30 selon juan g décide de tuer mais
ce n'est qu'à 11h30 qu'elle accomplira
son crime
quatre heures plus tard c'est long
quatre heures très long on a le temps de
réfléchir de laisser sa colère s'apaiser
de renoncer
solange disant je ne renonce pas à
l'heure prévue et le tue froidement
calmement et le lendemain matin quand
elle remet la robe à madame bovary que
celle ci lui demande si elle a passé une
bonne soirée elle répond paisiblement
très bonne merci et les sincères
la soirée a été excellente non seulement
elle se venge et définitivement venger
mais elle a aussi récupéré l'argent que
lui devait la malheureuse micheline
frugère chez bien neuf dans les numéros
se suivent et dont elle prétend contre
toute logique qu'ils représentent des
économies amassées au fil des mois
c'est évidemment un mensonge cet argent
ne peut être que celui de micheline
frugère récupérer à sa banque
quelques heures avant sa mort aucun
d'eux voulant doute elle s'en rend
compte alors alors avec un sens théâtral
auxquels je rends hommage élèves
elle avoue que tout le monde sait mais
peu lui importe
elle espère que vous prendrez cet aveu
pour la preuve de sa bonne foi de sa
sincérité et pourquoi pas de son
innocence
ce vol en réalité nous savons où et
quand ils là que j'ai jean-robert paquet
en même temps que le crime mais cela
évidemment ne peut pas l'avouer
alors que dieter qu'elle a pris l'argent
le lendemain matin
en attendant l'arrivée de police-secours
que le concierge était allé alerter
comment
voilà une jeune femme qui si l'on veut
bien la croire
viens de découvrir le cadavre de sa
meilleure amie on pourrait s'attendre à
la voir effondrée en larmes
on pourrait croire qu'elle va rester
auprès du corps leveillé pas du tout
elle profite de ce que le concierge l'a
laissée seule pour fouiller
l'appartement elle trouve le sac de son
ami louvre s'empare du portefeuille et
des robes l'argent qui s'y trouvent mais
c'est monstrueux c'est monstrueux et
cela nous montre enfin la vraie nature
de cette femme car cet acte ignoble dans
notés par elle n'aurait pas hésité à
l'accomplir c'est elle qui nous l'a dit
voilà monsieur la femme que vous jugez
aujourd'hui une meurtrière le débat
l'ont amplement prouvé et ses
dénégations ne pèseront pas lourd en
face du témoignage de mademoiselle
belfond non nous n'avons aucune raison
de mettre la parole en doute quant à la
préméditation je crois vous l'avoir
montrée elle ressort également de tous
les témoignages que nous avons entendu
qu'elle sera votre arrêt la loi est
claire tous coupables d'assassinât dit
le code pénal sera puni de main tout au
plus pourrait vous eu égard aux
multiples brimades et vexations que la
victime lui avait fait subir pendant de
nombreuses années et 30 lun à une
relative
or très relative indulgence je pense que
si vous prononcez contre elle une peine
de 15 années de réclusion criminelle
vous aurez rendu une bonne justice
maître vous avez la parole
je demeure confondues
après avoir constaté comme tout le monde
l'inanité des charges et la faiblesse
des témoignages je pensais que monsieur
l'avocat général allait abandonner
l'accusation et demander la mise en
liberté immédiate de ma cliente
il requiert quinze ans de réclusion
criminelle
à quel titre
en vertu de quelle évidence où sont les
preuves de sa culpabilité
on les a cherchés ses preuves on n'a
rien trouvé alors on se rabat sur ce
qu'on peut un ticket de cinéma que ma
cliente n'a pas concertés une poupée
casse sont driller de verre quelques
menaces proférées trois ans plus tôt
dans un moment de colère élan feint
d'oublier l'essentiel l'amitié
une grande et belle amitié qui durait
depuis l'enfance une de ces amitiés qui
repose sur une confiance totale absolue
lorsque micheline frugère se découvre
enceinte qui appelle à son secours
solange qui abandonne tout pour accourir
qui la voit plusieurs fois par jour qui
téléphonent toutes les heures où donc
est cette semaine cette rancune dont
parle monsieur l'avocat général
je les aime frugère disait quelquefois
de ma cliente qu'elle n'est pas belle
elle n'est pas coquette elle le sait et
ne s'en offusque pas la nature n'a pas
été très généreuse envers elle
enfin tout au moins pas sur ce plan mais
elle lui a donné des compensations une
très grande intelligence une force de
caractère peu commune et surtout oui
surtout d'inépuisables réserve d'amitié
d'affection dont a longtemps profité
micheline frugère durant sa trop courte
vie dans leur faute de mieux on vous dit
qu'elle est violente et on donne pour
preuve la ferme mon jir cendrier lancé
dans un moment de colère parfaitement
justifiée monsieur l'avocat
oui parfaitement justifiée micheline
frugère qui était d'ailleurs la
principale intéressée n'a donné un
incident que la valeur qu'il méritait
c'est à dire aucune la preuve débarque
en quelques semaines plus tard à paris
c'est à la porte de sol en ce qu'elle va
frapper et se l'ange la reçoit pendant
des mois mais parce qu'elle est heureuse
de la savoir près d'elle chez elle avec
elle ou ton et cette rancune cette haine
donc par monsieur l'avocat général
et où sont les preuves qui vous
permettent de tenir seul enjeu lusanger
responsable de la mort de micheline
frugère des responsables
il y en a on les avait vu tout à l'heure
à cette barre cette mr aulas ce père
tient un an après ne comprend toujours
pas ce sont eux les responsables
ce sont eux les coupables ce sont eux
qui ont abandonné leurs filles qui l'ont
laissé partir à la dérive
savez vous combien de fois ils sont
venus la voir quand elle habitait paris
une fois une seule fois et encore était
ce à l'occasion d'un voyage d'affaires
lorsqu'un jour micheline frégère leur
téléphone pour leur demander de l'aide
de la fiction
ils n'ont d'autre réponse que de
l'argent à lui proposer ce sont eux qui
ont tué leur fille
ou plutôt qui l'ont laissé mourir ce qui
est bien pire
mais que voulez vous quand la chasse les
affaires les cures le bridge occupent
tout votre temps on ne peut pas en plus
s'occuper d'une enfant qui réclament de
l'affection de l'affection en quelle
drôle d'idée un chèque en tiendra le 2
et lorsqu'un jour l'enfant mâle aimé se
suicide
alors on comprend plus
un gouffre
elle comprend
elle qui a tout fait pour se tenir là me
qu'elle voyait sombrer peu mais le 3
décembre 1971 elle a été impuissante
ainsi elle avait été à cette soirée
peut-être aurait-elle pu empêcher le
geste d'une fille mais elle n'y est pas
allé mesdames et messieurs les jurés
elle vous l'a dit pourquoi elle ne
connaissait personne elle avait peur de
s'ennuyer
alors elle est allée au cinéma et a
préféré se promener avant d'aller se
coucher
cette nuit là
micheline est morte parce que son amie
sa seule n'était pas auprès d'elle
j'aurais voulu demander l'acquittement
je suis sûr que vous l'auriez accordé
mais il ya les 3000 francs et comme vous
l'avez dit très justement monsieur le
président nul n'a le droit de se faire
justice soi même
peu importe de savoir si l'immense
douleur dans laquelle l'avait plongé là
la découverte du cadavre de son ami
l'empêchait de mesurer la gravité de son
geste pour ce geste
elle doit être puni mais cette punition
ne pensez vous pas qu'elle a déjà subies
depuis un an et demi qu'elle est en
prison
son jour et 500 nuits n'est ce pas payer
bien cher gestes commis dans un moment
d'égarement
c'est pourquoi mesdames
messieurs les jurés vous prononcerez une
peine légère de principe
une peine qui sera largement couvertes
par ces longs mois de détention
provisoire et vous ferez en sorte que ce
soir cette jeune fille retrouve une
liberté qu'elle a si chèrement pays
accusés avez vous quelque chose à
ajouter pour votre défense
c'est à dire seulement je regrette
je regrette d'avoir pris cet argent
c'est que tu ai dit si tu n'avais pas
sont terminés j'ordonne que le dossier
de la procédure à l'exception de l'arrêt
de renvoi soit déposé entre les mains de
monsieur le greffier les questions
posées étant conforme à l'arrêt de
renvoi considérons la lecture comme
l'ont fait les dames et messieurs avant
que nous nous retirions pour délibérer
du bloc de l'est lecture de
l'instruction suivante
la loi ne demande pas compte aux juges
des moyens par lesquels ils se sont
convaincus
elles n'ont alors prescrit pas de règle
desquels ils doivent faire
particulièrement dépendre la plénitude
et la suffisance d'une preuve elle leur
prescrit de s'interroger eux mêmes dans
le silence et le recueillement et de
chercher dans la sincérité de leur
conscience
quelle impression en fait sur leur
raison l'épreuve rapporté contre
l'accusé ait les moyens de sa défense
la loi ne leur fait que cette seule
question qui renferme toute la mesure de
leur devoir
avez vous une intime conviction j'invite
le chef de service des gardes à faire
garder les issues de la chambre des
délibérations dans laquelle personne ne
pourra pénétrer pour quelque cause que
ce soit sans mon autorisation linges et
messieurs les jurés veuillez vous rendre
dans la chambre du conseil pour y
délibéré avec la cour nous allons pour
en sortir qu'après avoir qu'une autre
décision car fait retirer l'accusé de
l'auditoire l'audience est suspendue
[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs les jurés nous
sommes donc réunis pour décider ensemble
du sort de solange lusanger vous savez
qu'elle est âgée de 24 ans célibataire
et qu'elle est traduite devant cette
cour d'assises sous la qualification
d'assassinât et de vol ce qui la rend
passibles s'ils nous retient nous sa
culpabilité et la préméditation de la
peine de mort si nous lui accordons le
bénéfice des circonstances atténuantes
nous pouvons descendre dans l'échelle
des peines jusqu'à trois années
d'emprisonnement et même eut accordé le
sursis puisqu'elle n'a pas été quand
l'année antérieure
je dois vous rappeler encore ceci pour
que l'accusé soit déclaré coupable il
faut que huit au moins d'entre nous sur
12 répondent oui aux questions qui
seront posées sur la culpabilité
si cette majorité de huit voix sur douze
n'est pas atteint l'accusé est acquitté
les votes sous secret les magistrats
n'ont pas de voix prépondérante et les
bulletins seront brûler dans la cheminée
avant que nous quittions place à la
voici en bref les questions auxquelles
vous aurez à répondre
il est reproché à solange danger à la
fois un homicide volontaire sur la
personne de michel fugère et un vol de
numéraires au préjudice de la même
personne
voulez-vous que nous examinions d'abord
si nous estimons à la lueur des débats
selon lui angers coupable d'avoir commis
un meurtre sur la personne de micheline
fugère un monsieur le premier juré à mon
avis il ya un doute et en
on ne peut pas on peut pas la juger
coupable c'est mon opinion personnelle
merci j'ai promis juré madame on a dit
qu'elle n'avait aucun motif de suicide
je suis pas d'accord parce que
évidemment philippe castets voulait
l'épouser mais on a plutôt l'impression
qu'il faisait sa part de voir que par
amour bien sûr il nous l'a dit dit oui
monsieur
on n'a pas pu être absolument certain
qu'elle ait été à cette soirée
on n'est pas absolument certain que l
epu est de faire dissoudre des
médicaments dans une ambiance assez
vaste puisque je crois qu'il y avait 47
personnes
on n'est pas certain non plus que
micheline frugère qui était une
comédienne du solide et réaliser son
suicide
monsieur il est très difficile d'avoir
une opinion bien sûr mais c'était quand
elle avait beaucoup de caractère elle
est très intelligente beaucoup de
caractère et alors je sais pas très
difficile à une opinion bien espérons
que vous allez vous en faire une avec
nous monsieur il y avait autant de
raisons de la soupçonné du meurtre et
d'autant de raison de considérer qu'elle
n'est pas coupat et d'autre part je suis
d'avis d'avocats et de
madame et monsieur l'état d'abandon
moral où cette jeune fille n'était
laissé peut laisser supposer que l et
été désorientés par cette grossesse
qu'elle ne souhaitait pas par le fait
qu' elle allait peut-être contracter un
mariage qui n'était pas un mariage
d'amour au maire maillage de force et
tout ceci il le fait aussi
et qu'elle est consulté un psychiatre
les débats nous l'andi a reçu de ses
parents pendant deux ans tous ceux ci
peuvent traîner devant laisser supposer
d'esquisser pensé qu' elle a pu se
suicider ce n'est pas certain mais le
doute subsiste
sylvain de présomptions qui paraissent
bien légère je crois que l' enquête n'a
pas été tellement poussé alors ça donne
un énorme doute oui mais ça je comprends
mais la déposition du commissaire ne
concerne que sa constatation du décès
mme ouimet domicile porte c'est
concluant très bien moi je trouve qu'il
n'y a pas du tout de de preuves
accablantes
c'était prémédité parce que elle voulait
aller
elle feint l'avait dit oui pour aller à
la soirée de ses amis et finalement
qu'elle n'y était pas allé parce que
déjà elle pensait à se venger
or ça ne paraît pas évident qu'une
personne ne puisse parler au cinéma sol
et se promener après même quand il fait
moins deux degrés de température on a vu
des hivers rigoureux on va quand même
faire nos courses donc je ne pense pas
que ce soit un élément contre l on voit
une fille résolue dans le travail
professionnelles intelligentes mais qui
est timide et 10 ont un sentiment
d'infériorité dans la vie personnelle
son seul point de réussite d'une
certaine manière dans sa vie personnelle
celle ascendance et l'autorité qu'elle a
sur son ami micheline or son été
intelligente mais qui est timide disons
un sentiment d'infériorité dans la vie
personnelle
son seul point de réussite d'une
certaine manière dans sa vie personnelle
celle ascendance et l'autorité qu'elle a
sur son ami micheline or son intérêt
psychologique propre à mon avis était
beaucoup plus de continuer à être la
grande soeur de micheline dont elle
avait déjà tout supporter plutôt qu'à
briser tous tout ce plan de vie qu'elle
avait fait sept
cette ambition qu'elle avait par un
meurtre dont les preuves tangibles sont
extrêmement réduits
c'est un petit peu je n'ai général ne
souligne pas deux points qui me
paraissent importants à son effigie
toile le premier c'est qu'il y avait non
pas un mais deux témoins qui vous
formellement reconnu selon lui l'engin
soleil à menzel elle fonde la revue et
puis aussi la jeune demoiselle papier
qui s'est rétractée à l'audience qui
revenu sur ses déclarations qu'ils
étaient impressionnés nous l'avons tous
vu elle était très émue et on peut la
comprendre il n'empêche que à
l'instruction et à plusieurs reprises
elle a reconnu selon jamais changé la
façon plus formelle et non deux témoins
qui l'avaient reconnu cours
d'instruction
je crois qu'on a fait le point dans
moins un élément l'a peut-être c'est que
solange lusanger était bien dans la
soirée elle vient bien les dragons tout
ce qu'elle ya bien les deux poteaux
personne n'a aucune preuve bien sûr mais
personnellement je pense qu'elle était à
7 soit gelabale oui car vous avoir
entendu au cours des débats qu'elle
devait aller chercher une robe et
mademoiselle madame veut vous ne verriez
vous même votre barrier a précisé qu'
elle sentait dans la personne de solange
un trouble une inquiétude ce qui
laissait supposer qu'elle avait appris
quelque chose
or si elle ne voulait plus à ce
moment-là aller à cette réunion
elle n'avait plus besoin de prendre
cette robe elle a eu l'intention de tuer
et la volée car elle voulait à tout prix
supprimez l'emprise que micheline
frugère avait sur elle qui était un
obstacle permanent il faut pas l'oublier
que ça lui a pris son premier fiancé
elle lui a pris le deuxième client sait
il y a indiscutablement pour cette femme
cette jeune femme une frustration
permanente dont l'origine dont la cause
et cela il ya une autre description
possible de la préparation à cette
soirée
selon je n'ai pas une mondaine
visiblement c'est quelqu'un qui
travaille qui passe sa vie à travailler
et csl est invité par micheline à cette
soirée elle s'en fait une joie elle
décide de faire des frais de chouettes
de prendre une robe se préparer et à ce
moment là elle se trouve dans un état
d'inquiétude des angoisses d'énervement
extrême que peut avoir une fille peu
accoutumés à des sorties et comme lcc
qu écouter ce courant pour une fille qui
s'est préparée à un plaisir qui croient
ne pas être à la hauteur et qui
préfèrent s'en priver que d'y aller
écoutez vous permettez que je parle
monsieur l'homme en tant qu' en tant que
femme dans la mesure où une fille qui
n'a pas été chez le coiffeur par exemple
et qui a préféré manquer un rendez vous
avec un avec quelqu'un plutôt que d'y
aller décoiffe et ça se voit c'est
possible et particulièrement pour elle
mais elle s'est promise un plaisir
malgré tout et elle se love iii elle va
au cinéma peut très bien admettre que
connaissant pas bien ça colle enfin son
ami l ai voulu puisque au téléphone lui
a pas dit qu'il était le père ou le
futur père savoir qui était ce père est
allé vraiment à la soirée pour voir ce
mot pour discuter avec son ami ce soit
en solo quand on lui a demandé s'il
avait passé une bonne soirée
il savait déjà que son ami était morte
il a dit oui très bonne pour moi ma
conviction est qu'elle a été à cette
soirée
d'ailleurs elle avait dit au départ
qu'elle n'avait pas pris les 5000 francs
les 3000 francs et mais bien sûr l'asie
à l'audience il a fallu cesse et c'est
dans son tempérament elle s'est trouvée
acculée elle s'est trouvée prise dans
scream et s'est trouvé pris dans ce vol
si vous admettez que elle se trouvait à
cette réunion à cette partie il est
indéniable que à partir de ce moment là
sa culpabilité est de plus en plus en
évidence car
nous on nous a dit que micheline ep soul
donc elle était déjà dans un état second
prendre des cachets les diluer dans un
verre les absorber dans un état
d'ébriété très avancé
il devient dit ne rien dire alors que
c'est une fille qui se raconte très
facilement et qui fait de cinéma est un
droit que ce soit sous forme de
vengeance elle était capable
oui il était saisi de rien chargé son
ami apprend que l'essai de récidiver le
premier simulacre de de celui-ci que la
belle frayeur s'il l'a fait devant tout
le monde
il y avait peut-être les gens
imaginaient qu'il y avait peut-être
quelqu'un qui pouvait passer dans la
pièce où elle était allongée pour maman
j'ai l'impression que dans une certaine
mesure il fallait au contraire quelqu'un
de bien réfléchi qui est fait tous ces
gestes et qui lui donnait à voir sous un
prétexte quelconque aveu même ne
serait-ce que pour rétablir la mickey je
crois qu'au contraire il ya
préméditation et enfin l'arme du crime
lui a été donné dans le sac de la
victime
elle sait pas elle qui a apporté une et
les médicaments alors après midi t il
aurait fallu qu'elle imagine que dans le
sac par la victime boirait qu'ensuite ça
je réponds à votre question est tout le
monde savait que dans ce sac qu'il
existait des médicaments dangereux car
mme micheline le répéter à tout le monde
oui donc elle le savait pour saler
qu'elle imagine que dans cette soirée à
se trouverait dans les circonstances
particulières
c'est peut-être ce qu'il a décidé
d'annoncer qu'il allait forcément
préméditation après ce nombre d'années
qu'elles ont vécu ensemble qu'elle
commence à en avoir assez des brimades
la victime micheline mais commis chez
les primates c'est un peu des des
coquelicots et calomnies a dit qu'elle
élève en dehors de la présence selon ge
mais en vérité seul angers tersannes
énorme pouvoir sur micheline bien c'est
peut-être cet appel à toi nous intéresse
c'est pas quelqu'un tout ce qui
m'intéresse depuis que l'équipe petit
salé pauvre elle a toujours su ville les
parents et b quel plaisir d'y inviter
quelqu'un il avait cet ami lagarde elle
a conservé cet ami puis un jour et n'a
pas réellement eu assez ou alors enfin
moi je suis à peu près persuadé
marocaine a rappelé que c'est plutôt
micheline qui conserve selon ge que ce
lange qui se concertent miss les
micheline c'est toujours micheline que
revient català des ennuis oui je ne sais
jamais solange qu'ils élisent qui ne les
arrange bien parce que ses parents ne
s'occupent pas belle parce que ses
parents lui donne de l'argent durant un
chèque
je dois reconnaître qu'effectivement la
responsabilité des parents et des normes
et dans ce drame
il revient maintenant parce qu'en fait
cette fille a été mais littéralement
abandonné mais abandonner une façon on
dirait presque parler de démission de
micheline
ah oui elle a été abandonnée abandonner
complètement par ses parents le père vit
à l'ère de tenue
même pas savoir ce que représente sa
fille ne se dise qu'il fait ni rien du
tout il notant qu'en page vous comprends
pas mais en fait pour revenir pour
revenir pour revenir à solange il ya
tout de même à fait que vous venez de
démontrer tout à l'heure car vous avez
émis des doutes donc en ce qui me
concerne
solange a menti elle a menti plusieurs
fois elle a menti
en ce qui concerne le vol de cet argent
elle a maintenu jusqu'à la dernière
minute que je ne l'avais pas pris et à
un moment donné quand elle a vu son père
elle a senti que son père était
bouleversé et à cette idée elle a dit
j'ai volé cet argent il y avait quand
même quelque chose qui est surprenant
voilà un mensonge flagrant
or pourquoi voudriez vous qu'il n'est
pas menti pour la pompe
pourquoi voudriez vous qu'elle n'est pas
menti parce que elle elle pouvait aussi
bien mentionné soirée et la liste
s'allonge il vole monsieur l'assesseur
et là elle a menti et elle a menti
plusieurs fois quand à moi puisqu'elle a
été à cette soirée donc elle a menti
pour la rose donc elle a menti pour le
cinéma donc elle a menti pour beaucoup
de choses qui croyez-vous qu elle aurait
été beaucoup plus coupable s'il avait
dit oui j'ai été assez de soirée
croyez-vous que il fallait apporter
autant de preuve à ce moment là mais je
crois au contraire que le fait qu'elles
disent qu'elles n'aillent pas à cette
soirée est beaucoup plus grave pour elle
parce que elle démontre effectivement
qu'il y a le besoin de lâcher quelque
chose
moi je dirai simplement un moonwalk
je pensais est actuellement à la suite
des débats et de tout ce que vous venez
d'entendre puissions procéder au vote
sur ce premier point
si vous êtes d'accord selon joe danger
coupable d'avoir commis un homicide
volontaire contre la personne de
micheline fruges est oui pour la
comptabilité
non si vous avez un doute alors vous
aussi vous voulez nous votons
monsieur jury voulez-vous palau güell
entre votre bulletin dans le passé le
passé comme ça
vous fermez niort nous l'avons placé
ou encore le pôle amont forme
la peur
voulez-vous n'a voté oui une fois l'eau
[Musique]
c'était l'avant sans lacets
j'en passe
il
t
[Musique]
l'audience est reprise
accusés levez-vous voici les réponses
aux questions et l'arrêt délibéré en
commun à la question sur la culpabilité
de meurtre
la réponse a été non à la question sur
la culpabilité de vol
la réponse a été oui à la majorité de
huit voix au moins
à la question sur les circonstances
atténuantes la réponse a été oui vu les
articles 379 400 et 460 3 du code pénal
vu les articles 366 749 et suivants du
code de procédure pénale la cour après
en avoir délibéré conformément à la loi
condamne l'usagé solange emilienne à la
peine d'une année d'emprisonnement et
décident qu'ils se rassurent si
l'exécution de cette peine
la colonne des points vers l'état fixe
au minimum la contrainte par corps
accusés vous avez cinq jours francs pour
vous pourvoir en cassation contre
l'arrêt qui vient d'être rendue passé ce
délai police auriez pu recevoir garde en
il a condamné l'audience criminelle
élevé
[Musique]